in this lesson you're gonna learn how to
find the least common multiple involving
variables so first what I want to show
you is a simple example involving just
two numbers like 14 and 20 and then
we'll apply it to find least common
multiple with variables so the first
thing you want to do is you want to find
out what are the factors that of the
number and when you talk about factors
what we're talking about are what are
the numbers that multiply together to
give us 14 well you can see 14 is like 2
times 7 and with 20 we know 20 is 4
times 5 and we know that 4 we can break
down into 2 times 2 so you're breaking
it down into the smallest components the
prime factors then what I like to do is
I like to write it in the prime
factorization notation so we've got 1 2
we've got 1 7 we've got two twos times 1
5 now what you want to do when you find
the least common multiples follow these
steps first factor then take the factor
that occurs not the least it's called
the least common multiple but we want to
take the one that occurs the most so
here you can see we've got one two two
twos so we're going to take the one that
occurs more to choose here we have one
five and no 5s so we're gonna want to
take one five one seven no sevens we're
gonna want to take the one that occurs
more one seven now if you multiply these
together we've got two squared is four
times five is 20 times seven is a
hundred and forty so what that means now
is that imagine if we had two fractions
like this say there was a numerator here
and we said oh I want to get a common
denominator that common denominator that
smallest anomaly that we could find
where 14 would go into evenly 20 would
go into evenly would be a hundred and 40
okay so let's jump over to example 1 so
what we're gonna do here is we're going
to look at 8 8 is really like 4 times 2
and 4 is 2 times 2 so you can see this
is really like 2 cubed and 20 we already
did that over here that's 2 squared
times 5 to the first so we want to take
what occurs of the most we've got three
twos here two twos here we're going to
need three twos we're gonna need one
five there's no 5s here and here we've
got x squared that's like two x's
multiplied together here we have one X
we're going to take the one that occurs
more here we have three wise here we
have five wives
take the one that occurs more so if we
multiply this together 2 cubed is 2
times 2 times 2 which is 8 times 5 is 40
x squared Y to the fifth and that's
going to be your least common multiple
or if you're thinking about finding a
common denominator now for number two
this one's a little bit more challenging
because what we have to do is we have to
see these are monomials like one group
this is a binomial this is a trinomial
what we want to do is we're going to
factor and see what this is made up of
so x squared minus 9 this is what's
called a difference of two squares and
you can factor it as a sum and
difference pattern see some has add
differences subtract so X plus 3 times X
minus 3 gives us back x squared minus 9
over here we have a trinomial with a
leading coefficient of 1 we just have to
ask ourselves what two numbers multiply
to negative 12 but add to negative one
that's going to be negative 4 and
positive 3 now here's where we want to
take whatever occurs the most right so
we can say well we've got 1 X plus 3 1 X
plus 3 it's a tie what do you do in that
situation well you're just gonna need
one of those ok so just it's a tie for
one there here we have an X minus 3 no X
minus 3 we're going to need whichever
one curves the most which so you can see
there's one here so that's one and then
we have an X minus 4 no X minus 4 we
need one X minus 4 now I don't have to
write these ones here because anything
to the first power is itself but just to
show you all these multiplied together
represents the lowest common multiple or
the common denominator if you're trying
to combine these into like a fraction
with the common denominator if you want
to see how to apply this least common
multiple to finding common denominators
and combining rational expressions
adding and subtracting follow me over to
that video right there and we'll dive
into some more examples I'll see you in
that video